[Musique]
et c'est un rendez-vous des juniors
rock'n'roll qui vous attend mélanie vous
avez un spectacle à découvrir dès 6 ans
à nous proposer
c'est ça les wackids viennent de
terminer ou un tour inter là galactique
quatre ans 400 concerts et il pose enfin
leurs instruments à l'espace albert
camus ne mord pas alors c'est un groupe
de rock composé de super-héros rouge
jaune et bleu et ils ont une
particularité il joue avec des jouets
d'enfants regarder
[Musique]
moi j'imagine québec vous avez reconnu
et oui johnny be good puissante reprise
est vraiment super mignonne avec les
instruments à sa rentrée
certains disent que non seulement beau
mais où un film un petit peu d'enfants
ce n'est alors bluesmaster bongo star et
speed fingers et les artistes
ils ont bien d'autres morceaux va vous
faire découvrir et d'en désordre yellow
submarine bohemian rhapsody bat biking
blague alors plein d'humour et
d'originalité vous l'avez vu les plus
jeunes vont sans doute vouloir rentrer
et testé quand ils seront à la maison
les plus grands auront peut-être un
petit goût de nostalgie le début du show
c'est à 20h30 le samedi 7 mars à m'en
faire et à coignières ce sera un petit
moment de poésie et de tendresse
là c'est la manivelle théâtre qui vous
fait découvrir l'histoire des lise et
léo il vit seul à l'abri depuis toujours
dans leur quotidien est rythmé par des
grains de sable
mais un matin les eaux laisse s'échapper
leurs chaussures et pour les retrouver
ils partent vers l'extérieur et ils vont
alors découvrez les trésors de la nature
et de la nuit regarder
[Musique]
la classe est fermée à clé ce n'est pas
la vie
je ne peux pas
on
ne connaît pas les pierres qui vous
emmène
se perdent et grave
[Musique]
où
soulié de salles c'est à voir à partir
de 2-3 ans ça permet de révéler ce qui
se cache derrière les peurs des enfants
lever de rideau à 17 heures au théâtre
alphonse daudet de quoi dire et comme
toujours toutes les informations à
retrouver sur les sites internet de
maurepas et de coignières merci mélanie
pour ces rendez vous